We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. to sort of put a coda on our discussion
of Donald Trump's health.
Here is a nurse who called in.
She's delightful, by the way, who says she
believes stroke may be the explanation for
Trump's trouble drinking water from favoring
one side when walking down that ramp at West
Point.
Let's take a listen to what she had to say.
David, you are absolutely the best.
Thank you.
Just watched your commentary about.
Some walking out at West Point.
Yes.
And I believe you had a stroke.
I'm a nurse practitioner.
I've seen a lot of that.
Anyway, thank you.
Thank you.
Yes.
A bunch of nurses actually wrote to me and
they said that the one sided thing that seemed
to be going on with Trump is to them indicative
of a stroke.
I am not making that claim myself, merely
telling you what some nurses have reported
to me.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the Trump administration
absolutely panicking about the upcoming release
of John Bolton's White House memoir.
Bolton, of course, one of Trump's former national
security advisers and the Justice Department
is now actually trying to take legal action
to block the publication of the book.
They are scared.
Boy Scouts of America, not typically the most
left wing organization you can imagine, particularly
when it comes to gay rights, is backing Black
Lives Matter.
We're going to talk about what they're doing
and how they're doing it.
And lastly, Albuquerque is going to put in
place a system where when a nine one one call
comes in, depending on what the call is about,
instead of dispatching armed police, social
workers will be dispatched.
This is one of the primary recommendations
I had in my multiple segments about how to
fix police.
Very interesting.
And we will talk about all of those stories
and talk about yesterday's chess tournament,
which had over 700 players participate on
the bonus show, get instant access by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com or by becoming
a patron at patrie on dot com slash David
Pakman show.